que nunca lograba entender.
Mi incompatibilidad de repente era compatible.
y por un tiempo, estuve mareada con esta nueva confianza
en mi manera de pensar.
Pero después de que mi abuela falleció, esa confianza se desplomó,
porque mi forma de hacer el duelo es mediante el pensamiento.
Y en ese dolor de pensamiento,
pude entender claramente
lo profundamente aislada que estaba y que siempre estuve.
¿Cuál era el propósito de mi humanidad?
Comencé a pensar mucho sobre como el autismo y el TEPT tenían tanto en común.
Y empecé a preocuparme,
porque tenía ambos.
¿Podría desenredarlos alguna vez?
Siempre me dijeron que salir de un trauma
se hacía a través de una narrativa cohesiva.
Yo tenía una narrativa cohesiva,
pero seguía a merced de mis traumas.
Todo era parte de mi sopa, pero las cebollas seguían apestando.
Y en ese punto, me di cuenta
de que contaba mis historias para hacer reír.
Había recortado la oscuridad, quitando el dolor
y aferrándome a mi trauma para la comodidad de mi audiencia.
Estaba conectando otras personas mediante el humor,
mientras yo quedaba profundamente desconectada.
¿Cuál era el propósito de mi humanidad?
No tenía una respuesta,
pero sí tenía una idea.
Tuve la idea de contar mi verdad,
toda mi verdad,
no para compartir risas,
sino para compartir el dolor literal, visceral de mi trauma.
Y pensé que lo mejor sería hacerlo a través de un espectáculo de comedia.
Y eso fue lo que hice.
Escribí un espectáculo de comedia que no respetaba el remate,
esa remate donde se espera que los humoristas saquen sus golpes
y los conviertan en cosquillas.
No paré.
Atravesé de un golpe ese remate
directo al estómago metafórico de mi audiencia.
No los quería hacer reír.
Les quería quitar el aliento,
dejarlos en shock,
para que pudiesen escuchar mi historia y sentir mi dolor
como individuos, no como una muchedumbre inconsciente y que ríe.
Y eso hice, y llamé a ese espectáculo «Nanette».
Ahora bien, muchos...
(Aplausos)
Muchos argumentan
que «Nanette» no es un espectáculo de comedia.
Y pese a que estoy de acuerdo con que «Nanette» no es un espectáculo de comedia,
esa gente aún está equivocada
(Risas)
porque han enmarcado su argumento
para decir que he fallado en hacer comedia.
No fallé en hacer comedia.
Tomé todo lo que sabía sobre comedia
todos los trucos, las herramientas, el conocimiento,
lo tomé todo, y con ello, rompí la comedia.
No se puede romper la comedia con comedia
si fallas en hacer comedia.
Flácido sea tu martillo.
(Risas) (Aplausos)
Ese no era mi propósito.
Mi propósito no era simplemente romper la comedia.
Mi propósito era romper la comedia para poder reconstruirla y reformarla,
reformarla en algo que pudiese sostener mejor
todo lo que necesitaba compartir,
y eso es a lo que me refería cuando dije que dejé la comedia.
Probablemente llegados a este punto dirán, «Sí, genial,
pero ¿cuáles son las tres ideas exactamente?
Es un poco impreciso».
Me alegra haber hecho de cuenta que preguntaron.
(Risas)
Estoy segura de que algunos ya han identificado las tres ideas.
Son una multitud inteligente, según dicen,
por lo que no estaría nada sorprendida.
Pero estarían sorprendidos de descubrir que no tengo tres ideas.
Les dije que tenía tres ideas, y eso fue una mentira.
Fue pura desorientación... Soy muy divertida.
Lo que he hecho en su lugar es coger a manos llenas mis ideas como semillas,
y las he esparcido a través de mi charla.
¿Y por qué hice eso?
Bueno, aparte de risitas,
se reduce a algo que mi abuela solía decir.
"No es el jardín, es la jardinería lo que cuenta".
Y «Nanette» me enseñó la verdad de esa perogrullada.
Esperé que al romper el contrato de la comedia
contando mi historia con toda su verdad y dolor
que eso me empujaría más lejos en los márgenes de la vida y el arte.
Esperaba eso, y estaba dispuesta a pagar el costo para contar mi verdad.
Pero eso no fue lo que pasó.
El mundo no me alejó, me acercó.
Mediante un acto de desconexión, encontré conexión.
Y me llevó mucho tiempo entender
que en el centro de esa contradicción
está también en el corazón de la contradicción
de porqué puedo ser tan buena en algo que soy tan mala.
Verán, en el mundo real,
me es difícil hablar con personas
porque mi neurodiversidad me dificulta pensar,
escuchar, hablar y procesar nueva información
todo a la vez.
Pero en el escenario, no tengo que pensar.
Preparo mis pensamientos por adelantado.
No tengo que escuchar. Ese es su trabajo.
(Risas)
Y no tengo que hablar realmente,
porque, estrictamente hablando, estoy recitando.
Entonces todo lo que queda
es que yo lo haga lo mejor que pueda
en crear una conexión auténtica con mi audiencia.
Y si algo me ha enseñado la experiencia de "Nanette",
es que la conexión depende no solo de mí.
Uds. juegan una parte.
"Nanette" puede haber empezado en mí,
pero ella ahora vive y crece en un mundo entero en otras mentes,
mentes que no comparto.
Pero con las que confío estar conectada.
Y en eso, ella es mucho más grande que yo,
como el propósito de ser humano es mucho más grande que todos nosotros.
Hagan de eso lo que quieran.
Gracias, y hola.
(Aplausos)